why God can I find answers why don't you
give me Insight in the truth that's that
I'm looking for and it suddenly darkened
my heart and I was startled and shocked
about the feelings at that moment
towards
God it really became hateful and I I
thought I can I can understand myself
that I'm so intensely struggling with
all these big topics but but this this
this is not good I just something
something is not right
here hey everybody Welcome to a LED live
that uh we're going to talk about a very
important issue especially with today's
culture and um there's a lot of things
floating around the world all sorts of
different ideas is how do you respond to
truth I had the privilege of meeting
Peter and his family when I was in the
Netherlands actually preaching at uh
some different locations over there and
uh this family came to some of the
meetings and I got a chance to hear a
little bit of their story and I wanted
to share it with you guys so welcome to
the show Peter thank you very much
Scotty it's a pleasure to be on the show
pretty uh early in my life I got a sense
of uncertainty when I uh got diagnosed
with a severe lymphatic cancer I was 5
years
old and um this uh was um pretty serious
and the doctors actually didn't expected
that I would be able to leave the
hospital um I've been there for four
months for an intense
treatment and um you see a a picture
here with uh my triplets sister
so I'm sitting in a bed and uh I still
can remember this uh this experience
when I look at the picture then a bit
bit fast forward I
um I started doing a study in uh in
Theology and philosophy and um it had to
do with questions that started
to uh pop up in my mind I grew up in an
uh Evangelical Church so I was uh
familiar with uh yeah a lot of things
from the Christian faith and from the
Bible but still uh I started asking uh
questions when I was 16 17 bit later on
like what what kind of things were
popping into your
mind
um one of the big questions was um what
I hear a lot within um also in
Evangelical churches is that
God wants to build a relationship uh
with with us and that's absolutely true
um but I was wondering that if that's
the case and and God want wants to build
a relationship with all all people
because all of us are created by Him um
why do we have so many different um ways
of life religions
philosophies um all over the world world
with so many people involved in all
those different kind of ideas and and
and and and
traditions um and even within the church
you see a lot of differences and that's
to say it in a positive way but you also
have
divisions um people not understanding
each other so that's that was a big
question um that came up another one is
um then I started think thinking about
the whole relationship between the
secular science and the Bible I always
knew and I was taught that in some kind
of way there is a conflict between them
and you should not go ahead with all the
like The evolutionary framework and so
on but I didn't really understand why
and I was also not really sure if it
really mattered right because right so
yeah how how how would we really know
how to determine you know way back when
something wasn't uh you know written
down or there's no video of it um but
you know I I I think that H the Bible is
gives us enough information and yeah
those those two things Evolution and
creation they they seem to completely
not
fit yeah that's true so um and one of
the things that I I learned that
sometimes when I have a conversation
with somebody who is not a Christian bit
maybe a bit skeptical about Christianity
or religion in general is the argument
that it depends on where you are born so
maybe if you are born in Kazakhstan you
you might become a Muslim or when you
are born in China you become a Buddhist
or and in the western world you're
likely becoming a Christian so but
regardless of the context where you grow
up everybody has a responsibility to
think about truth that's right so and
it's even if you grow up in a Christian
context you still have the
responsibility to think about what you
are being taught and um in some in some
ways I think it has uh
advantages because you get more familiar
with the Bible you have some background
information on the other hand it can and
also make it a bit more complex because
maybe you also are learning
stuff uh which looks like the real thing
but maybe isn't and then you need to
start um distinguishing between those
things and then and then difficult
questions start arising how do you find
your way through all of
this the Bible says seek and you will
find right yeah I mean it promises us
that if you go seeking God will direct
your paths he'll he'll tell you to go to
the right or the left and you know it
makes sense to me that God in his is
loving wisdom that he wouldn't just
leave us to our own you know random
questioning of the universe and then
there's no answers for it um but it does
take it does take some digging and when
you start to dig there has to be some
kind of line of truth that everybody's
judging off what's happening right it
can't just be relative to whatever
whatever truth you believe in is could
be different than everybody else's truth
there has to be some clear line
there and and this is was one of the big
the big things that I ran into because
once those big questions started popping
up I started looking for a a
comprehensive understanding what is what
is the truth how how should we
understand the Bible how should we look
at at at the world and and and the
history
and the the systematic approach that I
grew up with was sort of the the the
dispensational view and for those
viewers who don't have a clue what what
it is it's basically meaning that God
has uh sort of two projects that run
parallel within history he has one
project uh with the nation of Israel and
he has another project with the church
and I highly esteem the the way that I
um that the people within this view um
respect the Bible and treat it uh as as
um as a very important book uh and this
is also how I grew up within the within
the church uh but still I couldn't
reconcile myself with that and didn't
understand why but somehow I
thought is this really um um the the the
story line that the Bible tells so I was
on a path of all those questions
starting up coming up and piling up um I
I couldn't just come up with an
alternative because there was an
underlying struggle which had to do with
knowledge and
relativism just look around you and see
how many differences how many different
opinions there are uh outside church but
also inside the church um that's right
and then the question comes up who am I
to investigate
stuff the end I
will um I I will end up with my own
perception as well just like all the
other people uh have their own IDs and
their own convictions and and what's the
point of searching for
truth so especially in the in the the
postmodern climate that we have in the
western world you are discouraged right
from the start to look
truth because you're being told that it
doesn't make sense right or that it
doesn't have to make sense like you know
you can believe something that's totally
different than me and that doesn't
matter but to me that that that just
leaves this open-ended question of what
are we even doing here like like I I
think it's not a loving picture of God
to just let this experiment play out for
no parent reason I mean there's got to
be some reason that he's proving to the
universe or proving that his ways are
true and correct and that you know like
he he he wrote a law that that is should
be followed and um you know so there's
got to be some kind of purpose for it
and yeah postmodernism does not answer
the question of why is this experiment
happening exactly and um as you already
referred to uh this great quote of Jesus
that uh if you are if you search for the
truth then you will find it if you knock
on the door it will be opened and um
this is one of the problems with
postmodernism it it's not about um uh
our our capacity un to understand things
but it has to do with the underlying
attitude
are you willing to
investigate that's an interesting point
to humbly come at a a a teaching a
teachable spirit um something that you
you say Lord show me and I will I will
you know respond to that truth exactly
and that might have an impact on your
life so yeah which is which is why we're
having this discussion but you yeah
you're you're getting to this to this
this uh really interesting point and why
we why we uh we want to flesh this out
because how do you respond to truth
that's that's really what we're getting
at here yeah and uh so before I zoom in
a bit on how uh god um took me through
this process I want to give an
encouragement uh also to the viewers
that God often takes time in what he
does we live in a culture of I want it
all I want it now um but that that
that's normally not how how he works he
takes time in your life and I'm not
talking about weeks or months but most
of the times
years can get a lot of things very
quickly in our days experiences
entertainment uh Pleasures a lot of
stuff that uh that little light also is
uh evaluating and
reviewing um you can get it instantly
but it will leave you empty almost
instantly as
well and what God is doing it takes time
but it will endure and that's something
that discovered in my life and really
I'm grateful uh for that so don't be uh
dis disappointment or discouraged too
quickly if um if you're not directly
getting your answer or your solution in
life maybe God needs a little bit more
time to get you somewhere yeah you you
can see this example in many Bible
stories you know um God really wanted
Joseph to experience something amazing
but look at how many years it took of
Joseph going through some very trying
and and troubling times to you know if
he could just see from the beginning
from the end then he would have said oh
okay well God's preparing me for some
Grand thing but he had to be patient and
let God play that out it's an amazing
story of Joseph and that's and that's
exactly how God uh Works in our life so
and I think in some way it's also what I
experienced when I started um my study
Theology and
philosophy uh I needed to read a lot of
books and
um I
um I noted that um one once I started
writing something down
myself I was much better able to
remember it so I could read a lot of
books and then two weeks later think
well what exactly was it about what what
was the argument what was the line and
it's very easy to forget so I figured
out that if I write it down it's much uh
easier to understand it and to stimulate
your own uh thought Pro process about it
so in the course of the years I
collected uh a very large number of IDs
of quotes or sort of questions that that
I have and um so when I got married uh I
always had to to tell my wife don't just
throw my clothes in the laundry because
there might be a note somewhere in my
jeans
or all the day I was uh I was collecting
idas and um in the end it piled up to I
think about 2,000 pages of oh wow all
the stuff that um that I was thinking
about so when I was in the train
commuting to my work or at night or
during the day it doesn't matter I was
it was almost 24 hours a day and it
wasn't always um a nice thing it wasn't
a hobby it was more sort of a drive
inside of myself that I was
searching for something even if I
couldn't Define at that time what it was
and I could easily become agitated when
I couldn't wrap my mind around it and
when I didn't get the answers that I was
looking for and then I could become a
bit isolated and Silent which was I
think pretty tough for my family
time and then I just tried hard
but but not in the right way and um I
remember uh reading my own notes in uh
back in two 2014 I think uh which said
that I I couldn't even relax when I when
I took a shower so it was so it started
to be so intense you had a notepad in
the
shower yeah you're you're writing
writing in between your your
scrubbing that's awesome yeah yeah so um
but eventually it it also started
darkening my heart and it even
caused um hateful ideas toward towards
God because I I started to think here I
am searching for truth when I look
around there are so many people just
living their lives doing their things
and here's some person on this planet
trying to get
answers but I can't find
them it seems it seems like you don't
care and this has been a feeling that
has um yeah that has been troubling my
my heart for for quite from
years um yeah he it seems like um you
know the way God works with us is is in
a unique way that when you begin to
understand how he works the still Small
Voice the the orchestration of certain
events that happen in your life you can
see you can look back over it and on
this side of the of the conversation you
can you can say oh I see God was there
the whole time and he was working
through it but but I think he's
genuinely working that way so that
people don't treat him like a genie you
know I asked you something and you need
to just like pop up the answer like a
like a genie no it doesn't work like
that God is is generally you know
working through many different different
Vehicles how to bring understanding and
and I like how you said a slow sort of
progression of solidifying the truth in
your
mind yeah yeah and H I I have an uh have
an example of that of how that worked
out in my life so after about 15 years
of
struggling um one day he stopped
me and
it went like this I was squashing with
uh with my mate and was very
competitive um but then a few weeks uh I
tried to do my best to win the game but
it just didn't work out and at a certain
uh evening um I also really tried hard
doing this this this Sport and some
frustration popped up and suddenly it
started mingling with this huge
frustration that I had built up for
years and years of why God can I find
answers why don't you give me Insight in
the truth that's that I'm looking for
and it certainly darkened my heart and I
was startled and shocked about the
feelings at that moment towards
God it really became hateful and
interesting I I thought I can I can
understand myself that I'm so intensely
struggling with all these big topics but
but this this this is not good I just
knew something something is not right
here um so after the game I took a
shower and this was constantly going
through my mind what's what's going on
what what kind of feelings are there in
my my heart
and at that uh time I had to to go to an
address to to buy a present for my uh
for my son so I was looking looking up
the address where I needed to go and it
says it was the Garden of reflection
number six H so for me that was a sort
of contrast between the garden of e and
and God and this this whole um struggle
of me to with my own power thinking
power and reflection to uh to to to get
this answer and then so while I was
driving to this place suddenly the
thought popped up what if God would ask
you to throw
away
everything all your notes that you
compiled so far and within within
seconds I knew that it wasn't my thought
but
God asking me I rarely have uh heard his
voice so clearly in my life wow
wow so I got home and I I told Annes my
wife
well um just God just told me I have to
get rid of of all this stuff that are
piled up in in in in in these 15 years
oh and normally I'm not so Direct in my
character so she she knew okay this is
serious the whole evening I was busy
because I I stored those notes on a
thousand places because I was so afraid
of losing them so I had them on paper on
Toops on external drives on cloud
locations all over place so I was busy
the whole night deleting every every
single file I could uh I could find
and um this was for me was a very very
intense uh experience uh because this
was for for 15 years this was my whole
life Wow
and so the the the the it was on a
Sunday and then and the three days after
I was
really yeah how you say blown out of the
field I was just um very emotional
um um but then on I know I still
remember on a Wednesday uh on third day
um a great relief came in my heart wow
and it was so amazing and um and I
knew that God has had stopped me from
this road that led to a dead end
um this experience uh has increased my
trust in in God uh in in a in a
very special way it's sort of uh basis
in my in my life so that he takes he
takes the
risk to to to ask me
this and you responded to
it I I did by Yeah by his gra I I I
believe uh
so um
and and and this was such an enormous
relief and uh I was just uh for for
weeks thereafter I I didn't had any of
this frustration or ideas or feelings
that I had before it was all gone so
that was something uh um amazing you
know what I think is
amazing is is God sometimes allows us
to exhaust what we think we are doing to
fix the problem right uh Elijah you know
he sees Fire come down from heaven on
the top of Mount Carmel and the next
thing you you know it's like his life's
getting threatened and he goes and runs
you know a very long distance away and I
like how God approaches him you know
he's just like hey Elijah what are you
doing here you know it's like like like
just personable right you know and and
and I think it's beautiful that like God
let you for many years
he knew you were searching he knew what
you were doing and maybe that he needed
to let you have that kind of
frustration maybe maybe you were going
to listen more in this particular stage
than if you would have you know he would
have told you way back then so um I
think God's timing is always perfect
timing and it it sounds like it really
hit that hits you at the perfect
time it is and and this this story of
Elijah is a great uh example I actually
read it this week and uh somehow in
Elijah's life this had had become too
much his project he thought he was
failing and he was just sort of in
mystery and uh just it was all about
himself at the moment and then God
knocked at his door and said and don't
have all this pity with yourself I have
another uh appointment for you
so yeah so
so after this this
shift um I I still started thinking
about things because that's something
just it's my character it's how God
built me so to speak so um and I was
considering am I allowed to write this
down on notes or is should shouldn't I
do it and then I started I think maybe
just one paper um um and and then four
weeks later I was digging through my uh
my my inbox file to to clear it up a bit
and then I find I found one um email
that I I sent my work address because
that was one of the ways to to make
backups for me
and
apparently that single email uh was um
was an email that I
missed that night when you were deleting
stuff yeah
and so it has some some big attachments
to it with with a lot of
my uh previous uh like all the notes
which piled up so I I certainly
still I I did have my my large part of
of every everything what I collected I
uh sort of received it
again uh and my first thought was maybe
I needed to get rid of it um like like
the uh a few weeks before but then I I
experienced this peace in my mind my my
mind in my heart as if God said okay now
it's fine you can keep it um and later
on I saw in in this whole period all the
years I was sort of controlling I used
my mind to try and
control God to try and control the world
around me to understand it that lead to
the dead end
so now God in His Grace has had stopped
me and now I had a new starting point to
have a more relaxed way of going
about so um and then I I uh sort of
started with where I am now
um I started uh continuing with with a
book that I was working on already for
for a lot of of years and it had to do a
lot with uh with the
mind this was a of uh theme throughout
everything that I uh thought of in in in
the course of the last 20 years so and I
I think that in a lot of especially
Eastern philosophies you see a lot of
neutralizing your mental activity to
peace um but that's that's not what God
intends us to do that's right he says
come let us reason together he wants us
thinking right taste and test to see the
Lord is good like these are things that
are actively engaging us with him yes so
and and and you also have this this
great command of love love God with all
your heart all your soul and all your
mind good
point I was thinking about this uh of
course you can uh um explain it in a way
that you say it's good to do a Bible
study and then use your mind for the
right thing and that that's that's good
of course but I was considering could it
be even more in the sense that God
designed us to be loving creatures so if
we use our
abilities in a loving way they will
function the most in most optimal way
because that's how God designed so could
it be that our all
our whole thinking
process actually is also a sort of
special way of loving loving others and
loving whatever you think
about I I know I know that to be true
because um when you think of the flood
right the Bible mentions where the
people went wrong every thought in their
mind was evil
continually so you know it was like
almost the reverse veral of what you're
talking about right here they weren't
thoughts of other people and helping and
loving and being kind they were thoughts
of what how can I manipulate you and
harm you to get what I want you know and
and that was the point that God said he
he lamented that he had made man and you
know was was sorry because he saw how
dark their foolish Hearts were exactly
so it's very important for God what's
going on in our mind that's right in the
uh when you look at the characteristics
of love as described in the Bible I
think it's basically two things one is
the intention to to do just it's a lot
about doing just to your to to God and
to to your neighbor um and secondly
also um that you are are willing to make
costs for that so it's not just on but
you're you really want to commit
yourself you want to you give something
like time or money or to uh sure that
this other person or um also more in an
abstract way this other subject becomes
um you show it in a way that it really
is you want to do it just and uh this is
something that I discovered is also um
how our mind works so if with um so if
we ask one question at a
time we can uh instead of just give our
own quick judgment we can really present
something or somebody like it really is
and that's that's the character of love
and you also spend some time doing that
so this undivided
attention is actually uh a special way
of loving
others and
so this is uh this is how God designed
our mind um this how it works best in
also in everyday life in in uh and he
wants us to uh to to use it um in in in
that way and one of the things that I um
I discovered is once you do it once you
start taking the time to think something
through you get a new idea you get a new
perspective um and this this implies two
things that on the one hand um it is
Meaningful to think and this relates to
what we uh started off in the beginning
post modern
philosophy it discourages us to think
but it if you uh use your mind to love
you discover that it really has uh a
value and at the same time you also
discovered that your own knowledge and
your own perspective is apparently
limited because you discover something
new that you didn't knew and so this is
um when I look uh to my relationship
with God this is a very very
important um thing because he wants us
he wants me and he wants you and he
wants all the viewers to to think about
things but at the same time he knows
much more than us he has a much much
broader uh perspective on things than we
so there's also this always this room
for okay Lord this is what I
think this is my what the best what I
can do but there's always room for God
to guide you to intervene and to say
well okay but maybe I have a different
take on
this and um I think one of the
um Bible verses that that that that have
become really important for me is from
Psalm
86 and it's teach teach me thy way oh
Lord I will walk thy truth
unite My Heart To Fear Thy
Name and so he
unites our heart with all the thoughts
going on in our heart so when we are on
our
own when we are going our own way like
uh we are being taught in the culture
our thoughts go in all kinds of
directions and they become messy um you
become you have a lot of unrest in in
your heart but when you start to trust
God and see that he has a a broader
perspective and bigger picture also on
your
life then he's starting to make this
this mess of everything that you think
he's starting to organize it and he's
uniting your
heart why looking up to him for for
guidance in your life so that's that's
wonderful uh yeah you know you know I
imagine that God designed us this way
for an eternity if you live for billions
and billions of years your mind needs
new discoveries there's going to always
be moments that we're sitting down with
God and God's going let me teach you the
reason why this is the way that it is or
or you know guiding us even through an
eternity in a closer and closer walk
with him how to be others focused I
don't think that there's going to be a
time that like we arrive or whatever we
think okay I've got all the knowledge
that I need to know and I'm good from
here on out we will constantly forever
sit at the feet of Jesus and be added by
the the depth of love that he had for us
to come down to this planet to do this
um this will be a study I believe
throughout you know billions and
billions of years yeah it absolutely is
and I love that you bring it up because
what you see in the Western World you
see a divide on the one hand the
pretention that we can know everything
that we can understand life to to its
full and and control it also and
manipulate it um on the one on the other
that that's more the modern stream then
the postmodern stream does the opposite
says well no it doesn't have makes any
sense you you cannot discover anything
so it's it's the total opposite but yeah
uh but God is infin infinite so what he
creating um he is able to to sustain us
forever so we will never get to the this
this point that we comprehend
everything because uh everything is not
our starting point God is the only one
who's Eternal and who who will uh
sustain us for forever so we will use
our mind in
eternity love and to love God
yeah yeah so uh this this has been a new
starting point point for me
to um to sort of ask ask this the same
questions that I struggled with before
but now in a more relaxed manner I could
come it much much better so and this
helped me also when I started having
some troubles within the church that I
attended so what what where yeah where
your is your family at at this point
with going to church are you guys pretty
actively engaged in church you go every
weekend you you studying things out as a
family or how's your family at this
point
yeah so at that stage they were um
pretty young yet I was a um part of a a
Baptist Church in the center of the
Netherlands um so they they were part of
it um with uh all other activities were
organized for them but they didn't
really had a lot of connections with a
connection with what happened in the
church um and at that stage the my kids
were not really able to uh to
explain why it was that was a few few
years later when they started
understanding things better so we have
uh now they're uh they're uh older uh
the oldest is 17 and we have a lot of
conversations together about um about
the faith about what's happening in the
world around us what happening in the
church all the ideas that um are uh
promoted uh in the world so um but at at
this stage it was more myself and my
wife Arness we were very conscious of
what what was going on this in this uh
Church um and um yeah that that took
also quite a long time I think we have
been part of this church for about 18
years so the kids W weren't even there
yeah so you raised kids in this church
basically yeah exactly yeah so uh um and
and the first the first few years were I
think we had we had a very good time and
we um We Got U we had a lot of new
contacts and we started doing some some
some Bible studies together uh was uh
very constructive and inspiring
situation but then it it started it's
going um down uh
quite yeah quite quickly um what was the
Catalyst what what what kind of caused
some issues in is it something you were
studying or how did
you yeah so one of the main things was
that at a point they needed a new
preacher and uh so they proposed one and
um the whole process started but um I
looked a little bit into who this person
was and what he was standing for and he
was actually elevating doubt as a virtue
so oh interesting yeah doubt everything
so that's that's very cool if you can do
that uh in in his perspective so is that
is that a concept in philosophy like I I
know um there some of those early
philosophers I mean that was kind of
what they were after right yeah yeah so
D plays a very big role um and this is
tricky because on the one hand as we
just uh saw that God wants us to use our
mind and it means that you ask questions
and that you can have doubts but however
if um if you start with doubt and you uh
sort of
um everything there is will be uh you
make subject to your to your own
reasoning
capacity then there comes there enters
an element of force and power within
this whole concept so now you're not
just asking a good question but you Al
you want to get a sort of um uh
dominance and power over whatever you're
thinking about even even about God so
he's that's what I honestly believe
Lucifer did in heaven I think that he
raised enough doubt and planted this
seed in people's minds means that that
began to be the basis of people not
trusting God so doubt can be damaging in
that way if it's like you know things
are brought up that that you know either
you know really put a wedge in between
your understanding and and it can really
wreak havoc on your on your relationship
with God yeah and there's a big
difference um from uh from the out uh
outward appearance it might look the
same but you can ask tough questions and
that's fine but you can do it I think
basically out of two motivations one is
that you want to uh you want to love God
and you want to search for the truth and
that's the reason why you are struggling
with diff difficult questions the other
route is that you are you actually want
to get rid of God and of the truth so
you're using all those different ult
questions just so that you don't have to
do anything with that and doesn't impact
your life and it might look the same at
first glance but it's
really a difference of uh yeah yeah one
will one will deconstruct your faith and
one will cause you to like you know go
and search things out but yeah you you
have to have that sort of open trusting
heart to God and even though you don't
understand something God I'll let you
you take the time to show me and I'll
trust that you will show me yeah exactly
yeah and there is a lot of room with God
you see it also in in the Psalms for
instance for people to just bring on the
table whatever what's whatever is in
your heart whatever on your mind so it's
not that we need to sort of always um
discipline oursel and say okay maybe I
have something that's bothering me but I
I need to I need to trust then I need to
no God can deal with that he has a lot
of lot of experience with with us
so it's it's important to to um look
um to test yourself uh in in in in in
the sense of what what motivates me what
drives
me so uh so this was a big point in the
whole uh development in the church and I
I was surprised but also a bit shocked
about this uh yeah this idea of of uh uh
proposing this this man to be sort of
sort of uh leader within the church
while he was throwing away all the truth
himself so but but at stage I I thought
that's just maybe a small portion of the
church just a few who who want to push
it this
way um but in the course of the years it
became uh clear for me that this whole
this postmodern idea uh was preting more
and more and affecting uh everything
that we were doing and this sort of
accelerated uh when the whole um covid
thing started in in
the uh in in the past years and I
remember that uh I had to preach on uh
on Christmas so um but the day before um
another person was was preaching on the
24th in the evening and basically was
telling well we don't need to we don't
uh we should not look at um uh like sort
of conspiracy ideas and and things going
on in the world we we only need to focus
on what's positive and what gives a good
feeling and I knew that the story that I
was going to tell the morning after was
quite the opposite because I wanted to
sort of um present on the one hand the
the the worldly way of looking at the
future that we are going to build our
kingdom we're going to make peace and
and and safety and we're going to do it
tackle
Thessalonians when they say peace and
safety and sudden Destruction come upon
the them like a travail upon a woman
yeah that's that's that's where we're
headed is they're calling for peace and
safety and that's when the destruction
will come yeah so and then comparing it
with uh yeah the plan that God has in
mind of eventually building his kingdom
of Peace of course but it's going
through crisis so and it stirred up a
lot of things and uh I got quite some
complaints uh of uh yeah of why I uh
brought this this about I would make
people
maybe people would be
uh yeah anxious fearful whatever um so
in the end I was not allowed to preach
anymore and it strengthened my um my um
my
conviction that there is a a huge
difference in how we view the future
right yeah and how how you view the
future has a lot to do with how you view
the past right and and what you and what
you do in the present like if there's
something in the future that God is
bringing us through because I I don't
think it is a loving picture of God if
he's up there just waiting for a clock
to tick away time I mean think of all
the people that are living in life and
misery sheer misery there's there's
people that are engaged in human
trafficking and slavery and you you know
awful things that are even hard to speak
about why would God wait for that unless
there was something that had to happen
there has to be something that that is
the reason why we're going through this
mess at this point yeah exactly so um so
that brought me to the point that I I I
thought by myself I think what is
missing is an understanding
of um of what it's all about what's the
bigger picture of the of world history
why is why why did God start all of this
U and what is he doing what what what is
our role today and what can we from the
future so uh I see a lot of um also
Christians around me have all kinds of
opinions about topic A or B or C and
everybody has uh his or her own idea
about a lot of things but the question I
started asking more and more what what
is the bigger picture what is the
storyline what is it what is it about
and um so uh and and I saw that also
within the church this often is seen as
a sort of secondary matter so thinking
about the start of the world uh God
create uh the whole story of uh B Babel
and whole the uh people dispersed
throughout the earth the earth it's it's
more seen as something that's maybe an
inspiring story or it doesn't really
matter if it's really happening if if it
really happened in the past and these
these ideas are very popular within the
church but I are very damaging because
you're not you're not just talking about
uh a difference of opinion about one
topic but you're actually changing the
whole concept of of truth from what's a
reliable story about our life about the
real world you're changing that into
something that's just something inside
you
feeling some perspective that you might
have on on on on the world so that's a
major
change um and um I think unfortunately a
lot of Christians also don't really
realize what he impact is of this oh and
this started uh this kicked off sort of
process that I uh I started creating uh
the a timeline uh to sort
of uh help others see what are the the
major milestones in what God is doing
and how does it relate to the real world
MH from the start up till the present
World stage and even into the into the
future and uh this has been a project
that my Alo my kids really started
engaging in
because I I saw in their life that that
something uh they discovered something
this is this what God is doing is not
just a a nice story this is this is the
real thing and there the more and more
they started seeing it
um themselves as well so I organized
some um uh some Bible study series of 12
evenings at my house and and my kids
were very much involved they uh they
were looking forward to it to an extent
that I didn't
expect they really love being part of
this because they they started to get a
sense of this this is really what it's
all about right it it's it's something
that I believe you know God wouldn't
just leave us to random and not give us
answers and so when you begin to
discover the answers of how he's worked
in the past how he's working in the
present and well how he will work in the
future I think it gives your life
purpose and you begin to look at what
you're doing is like there's a reason
for it all and and here's what I need to
contribute to this you know MH yeah yeah
and this is exactly and and we live in a
in in a day and age especially for the
younger people um that there is so much
uncertainty
um and if there is so much uncertainty
you need to ask very big
questions um about what is uh the basis
of your life what is um what is your
Anchor Point why does anything matter if
you want to answer that kind of
questions you need to look at a very big
picture because it has to be you cannot
just say well God God loves you that
that's fine and it's true but it's not
enough yeah what how do we respond to
that and how do we order our lives
knowing that God loves us
unconditionally and um you know he he's
he's worked with people in the past
where he's asked them to do certain
things and if those things weren't done
there there were consequences of some of
those things so is that mean for me too
is there consequences to my actions I
mean all those things play into it's not
just God is love and he's just going to
love everybody regardless of what
happens down here it's true he loves
everybody but he's wanting something to
be done down here that is going to tell
a bigger picture about who he is to the
universe ex exactly and uh and it's it's
vital to to ask the question of what is
the real story of our life because if
you answer if you're are able with God's
help and and based on the Bible and
together with all people around you can
help you if you are able to find answer
you also know uh why you are there
yourself why it matters what you do what
you think uh what your role is in in
this this whole whole epic that that God
has started and and and will complete so
and so you started asking these
questions and this is this is coming to
the surface during your Bible study here
yeah yeah so uh and uh it I it's
uh I I had this opportunity to uh to do
this with some some of the people at my
house but that's quite quite limited so
uh that's why uh I I started I started
the YouTube series as well because I
thought well this is something that
needs to get out there this this people
need to know this they they need to be
able to think about this at least to to
hear what uh what the God is doing
throughout all the ages why he started
how it developed how also when you look
there's a lot of um things going on in
our world today but you cannot
understand the current world stage
without what uh like what what led up to
this whole situation it's imposs
possible and the Bible gives you the
anchor points to uh to start to
understand it um that's that's really
really helpful I believe especially for
younger generations to see well this is
really this this is really it so what
kind of truths were you discovering with
this group was it different than what
you know maybe the church was was
teaching at the time yes
um what I discovered is that um it it
does make it big difference that uh how
you
view um the start of history that we are
actually that we have a young history um
that the Earth is is still young uh that
Humanity relatively still young of
course the secular framework talks about
millions and billions of years uh the
Bible uh speaks about very short even
about six 6,000 years of History uh that
amazing if you think about it and I can
imagine that for a lot of people think
well that's ridiculous but uh it isn't
ridiculous right there's uh there's a
lot to um to say and to discover about
it and this also makes it more realistic
that the in the current
Generations um are part of this let's
say we have about 180 Generations before
us that's not so much and so we're
we're it's not only
about um a good feeling it's not about
an abstract idea of well maybe it's good
to do in your life but it's
understanding that you are
part of this history that God is working
out um and so that was uh that's I think
uh makes makes a big change
and it has a lot of um when you start
reasoning about it it has a lot of
effects and um one of the things also
about God is the
creator um he
defines um the the rules in his in his
kingdom and he has rules and um maybe we
are inclined to throw away all rules in
the
world right I I I want to design my own
life I want to determine the rules
myself um but that's that's a dead end
and God has given us his his perfect uh
law right that um is is is the basis of
of his kingdom of and it it's really uh
something valuable this was a new
discovery in in in including yeah a lot
of topics that there's a lot of topics
that that that eventually come up
um and also has to do about with the
history that is one one of the big
questions that I I had for a long time
is what about the past 1900 to 2,000
years so I grew up with you have you
have the Bible stories and you have the
the church they have a major Gap and
then suddenly you have the hear and now
what about this time in between and also
during this um
uh in the past years I started looking a
series total Onslaught oh yes from so um
and this asked uh uh this answered uh
basically this this question that the
passed 1900 years between the early
church and where we are are now also
matters and a big deal and has a lot to
do with also how our maybe our
Traditions uh within the Church also has
have grown in a certain direction and
things that maybe you have taken for
granted because it has been like this
for
Generations um still need to be
reconsidered
maybe one of one of the things that we
are um that was new for us was a whole
question about um the the Sunday in the
Sabbath uh is that thing was absolutely
new for me
but once I started to see that God
really is the creator not just as a sort
of concept but he really is he he kicked
off the whole history and he said okay
this this is this is my uh my this is my
law this this is how my kingdom is is is
set up I really need to to consider this
even if it's really new this is true and
and this is like um part of of I like
how people have framed this conversation
about Sunday or Sabbath like you know
this God set aside this day and he told
I mean I think it's the one Commandment
that says remember don't forget this one
right because he was looking through
time going this one's going to be
forgotten and times are going to change
that's why you know Revelation talks
about to to the to the man of sin that
thinks to change times and laws right um
those those things that are set in stone
were set in stone in the very beginning
of creation and they point to God as the
Creator God and so if he if he is
hanging out with us you know and he says
I'm I'm setting aside this special day
you have six other days over here you
can do what you you need to do and work
and and and do what you know you feel
life is is calling you to do but I want
to hang out with you on this one day
nobody comes to him and says well I'm
just going to give you Wednesday I'm
just going to give you Thursday if God's
like no I I want to I want to hang out
with you on on the Sabbath
and so you know times have changed over
the years but when challenged to find
the evidence where in the Bible does it
say it was changed to Sunday there is no
evidence in the Bible for Sunday
worship yes and and very interesting as
well is that this power that the Bible
talks about is about to change the times
and the law uh it doesn't say says that
the power is going to abolish it right
it's going to change it so it's going to
make an own version of it and this is
one of the lines that I started seeing
that uh that God's enemy is always
making lookalike versions he's making
all fake versions of what God is doing
so if if God has given us um uh with
creation he has given us this this day
then it's it's quite likely that his
enemy comes up with a sort of
alternative is he to change it and in in
this way going to say okay who who can
determine the rules that's of course the
it's not about it's not just a practical
issue it's about who's setting the rules
therefore it's grounded in in the in the
Commandments of God he is the Creator
and therefore he can give uh can give
the the right rules to us right do we
follow do we follow him because of his
supreme authority and if he tells us to
do something is are we ordering Our
Lives because God said to do it or are
we saying that's not really convenient
for me uh the rest of the world worships
on this day and so it's just it's just
I'm going to Worship On this day because
that's that's that that's why I think
that there is a really really good
reason why the Sabbath is still the
Lord's day that he wants us to worship
on yeah so and to be honest I I still
need to get used in some kind of ways of
how does it work in our in our life what
practical implications does it have and
um but we want to take it serious and
and say okay if this is the line that
God has given us uh as Humanity then we
want we want to really consider it and
say what what the impact of this is in
in our life and uh then this will likely
will maybe even in the upcoming years it
will become even more clear that there
is this Con contrast about who do you
follow who do you acknowledge and what
do you who do you ultimately trust your
life
to yes this is true I I believe with all
my heart that that we are gearing up for
the last struggle between good and evil
and uh a lot of people think you know
the Antichrist it's going to be this
very easy to spot thing it's going to be
opposite of God and uh you're going to
recognize it real quick because it's a
devil that's wearing a red cape and a
pitchfork and that's not how it's going
to play out at all it's a religious
ending of this who's the authority of
worship and what what God do worship and
and that worship will be forced there
will be laws that will be set in place
that that that say you need to uh
worship on this particular day and if
you don't there's consequences for that
and God is never forceful and so as
we're speeding through this I think it's
very like timely that you have been um
really starting to study out this topic
you're asking the right questions and
then God is leading you to understand
who who's who's the rightful
Authority
yeah he does so so you started studying
this out in your little group um what
did you do with that information did did
you bring that up in the whole
group um so
the um we we already uh before we
started this this uh this group at my
home we already um departed from the the
church Baptist Church where we were
because there was too much of a conflict
there between uh how they dealt with
truth um in
the um the current group that I had in
my house was very mixed group because I
did it on my own initiative so it was
just whoever wants to come okay um so it
was uh interesting to see all the
different way uh ways people interacted
and responded to this and you see that
makes it takes some time because it's so
different in in in a lot of ways
compared to I think what you could say
is more the mainstream conservative
Protestant Evangelical
way of thinking about these things MH oh
um for some of them I uh I have in depth
conversation with still and they're
really thinking this through and and
trying to find what does what do this
what does it mean in my life others
maybe it will take some some more time I
I I'm I'm not sure in all cases but uh
um there's definitely something that's
you you start uh thinking about these
issues and once you sort of open up the
door you you yeah you discover a lot of
things you you start asking a lot of
good
questions um so I see this process has
started with quite a few people who
attended this uh these
meetings um and then I I tried to talk
with it with whoever wants to to hear it
so even if I'm uh um
talking with my colleagues who are not a
Christian but maybe some of them are
interested most of them unfortun of for
fortunately not but some of them are um
but also within the family of course um
and you get very different responses
responses but uh
overall um when when I um when I'm able
to to show that this is not a stand
alone issue it has to do with this whole
world history um then
it's my experience people start to to
understand it it's it's about this
bigger picture and this this question
that I that um uh that came up a few
years so what what is what is the bigger
picture of world history and this is has
a lot to do with that so once you go
through this step step by step uh you
get to the point that you say okay I
really really need to think about this
this is also what I try to uh uh
accomplish with the with the YouTube
series that I currently are publishing
uh which is in Dutch so it might be bit
difficult for a lot of the viewers but
maybe with some translate option or so
um but I try to to to uh to to take the
listener step by step um and to see how
you get to this point and why it is
important to think about these things so
um so in the current the church that I'm
now attending um I see that
conversations start coming up as well at
the same time the to be realistic it's
sometimes quite
tough can give
uncertainty uh uh it pops up of all pop
all kind kind kinds of questions pop up
regarding uh the grade and law and and
so forth a whole bunch of questions that
that we could would talk for an hour
about um but I think uh I try to focus
on what God has given me um and the
responsibility that he gives me because
I cannot change the world I cannot it's
it's not my uh project after all it's
his uh but uh I he gives me uh
responsibility as um some of the options
that I have some of the people that come
on my way in my life and I try to to
converse with with them and and help
them
find um find the truth and take a stand
in um yeah in in in the current days and
and especially in in the years to come I
think I think it's very beautiful when I
met you and you came to some of those
meetings you know to see your whole
family there and to talk with some of
your children who have also invited
their friends to come and learn some
some new things um it's neat to see a
whole family and and it's like you know
it can be a very uh uh difficult
situation if you respond to a piece of
Truth and maybe your church doesn't
respond to the truth in that way um and
you you feel a little bit isolated but
your family is just picking up this this
uh this truth and just all of a sudden
sharing it with those around them and
that is a very awesome way to deal with
it and um this God is a god of answered
prayers truly I I stand firm on that
that belief that if you seek you will
find God will show you if you knock that
door will be opened up to you God says
come let us reason together he's wanting
us to understand why he does what he
does what what is the great picture like
the big picture perspective that you're
talking about I think those kind of
Concepts God gives us but he wants us to
seek them out you know and and sometimes
we've fallen in a rut of maybe listening
to tradition of of of churches and we
don't even understand why we do those
things that we do and so to sort of take
a step back and and and say okay God I
want you to show me in your word why is
this the truth and why is that um the
way that it is I know God will actually
lead you and guide you through those
things I hope the viewers will get get
this out of the the conversation that it
it's really valuable and it really makes
sense to search and to knock on the door
it it's uh Jesus didn't give his promise
for nothing if you really want to do it
if you have this intention of doing this
he will guide you and it might take some
take some time um but that's fine in the
end you show you the way so don't take
everything for granted uh but uh yeah
try and dig uh in in in dig into this uh
this these important topics and also if
you if you are parent or in some other
way uh involved with with
children um it might be nice to to have
another chat maybe about it but um it's
very important that you understand
yourself um what your conviction is
because um only if if you have uh
thought it through and and struggled it
through maybe also together with god um
then others will see that it's um
trustworthy and that they they they it's
not just something that you bring up but
that you are able to to explain in your
own words also what you mean and that
you it's not repeating some maybe some
some author or Pastor has said no you
need to it it needs to be your
own also yeah I think that's why God
wrote it down thousands of years ago he
wrote down what was going to happen you
can't guess the world what it's going to
happen the direction it's going to go
and prophecy was there to really teach
us how to trust in God he tells us
exactly what's going to happen he's
given us lots of information but it's
our job to dig through that to ask for
the understanding to to to allow God to
Bubble those truths to the surface and
and and to ask for the Holy Spirit to
make sense of what we're reading right
he's the one spiritual things are
spiritually discerned because God's the
one that's that's that's telling you
what those things mean and so when
you're actively engaged in seeking for
truth and asking God for wisdom and
understanding he will direct your paths
I believe it
um Peter thank you for for blessing us
with the story of your journey of Truth
and uh what you did to respond to that
and um for all of our viewers at home I
hope that you guys will take a lesson
from today's discussion and um you know
learn to trust God learn to put him to
the test learn to ask him to show you
what those truths are from his word and
you will be amazed at how God directs
your path has and be able to humbly
accept even if some of those things are
very different than maybe what you grew
up to believe um if you're really asking
for for God to show you what is the
truth of this thing I don't believe that
he will ignore you and you will be
amazed at how many times he will answer
your prayers so Peter thank you I look
forward to the next time we talk and uh
to hear more from you but uh this was a
great great beginning of the backstory
of your family and uh thank you for
taking the time and and and chatting
with us it's my pleasure Scotty and I
wish uh blessings uh for all of the
viewers as well may God guide you on the
road awesome we'll put a link to Peter's
Ministry in the discussion uh or in the
description below keep them in your
prayers as well keep us in your prayers
thank you for watching this video like
And subscribe to our Channel and if you
feel that this would be beneficial to
somebody an easy way to enter into
Ministry is just copy this link and send
it to somebody that you think would be
blessed thank you for watching we'll see
you next week
[Music]
created you oh
Jacob and he form you oh
Israel I will make him a pillar in the
temple of my God and he shall go out no
more I will ride on him the name of my
God in the Lord and in the
power Lord shall
[Music]
Str alone but by every word that
proceeds from the mouth of God
I'm sorry do we know each other it seems
like maybe we've met before I don't know
this is uh it's awkward though just as
much for me as it is for you I really
wish I had a conversation starter
[Music]
oh hey oh what's on my shirt and this is
the story of the Three Angels message
from Revelation 14 wow that totally
worked you know if you have trouble
starting conversations like me maybe you
should try lightwear
[Music]
[Applause]
St